peace be with you welcome to the D show
if you have not subscribed subscribe
right now my next guest grew up in
Baltimore she is a graduate student and
pursuing her MBA her mother is a Baptist
minister she grew up in the Baptist
Church and wasn't a Christian sorority
thought Islam was of the devil that she
started using her mind and came across a
Muslim who corresponded with her talked
to her and her heart just connected and
she's here on the Dean show to tell us
how she went from confusion to a way
that's clear straightforward and is the
way of Jesus that's right and all the
prophets of God so this incredible story
with my next guest don't go anywhere
exciting exciting we'll be right back
and welcome back to the D show with our
special guests Bianca salaam-alaikum
Bianca peace be with you thank you for
being with us here on the D show now I
opened up the show and I talked about
your mother
she was actually a Christian minister
you actually came from come from a back
Christian background were in a Christian
surah t and tell us some what somebody
in your currently studying to get your
MBA
tell us a little bit more about yourself
I'm Baltimore as you said I'm currently
working on my MBA and shall I be
finished by next year I did grow up in a
Christian family we used to attend the
Baptist Church on some of my family
members still attend some don't
currently I grew up on a church every
Sunday we didn't really put a Bible
study but we went to church every Sunday
sometimes Church that last 3-4 hours and
once I went to college I decided that I
wanted to figure out who God was on my
own and still just having that Christian
background and not really knowing
anything else besides that I sought out
God in the church and also I joined a
Christian sorority and I danced better
to learn more about my religion you had
mentioned something about thanking the
creator who brought you out of
discontent and confusion what was this
discontent and confusion that you were
in before Islam where
join the church all night wanna wait for
my family I went to church every Sunday
I went to Bible study I went to the
meetings and something just didn't feel
right and I started not going to church
I started staying home on Sundays and I
felt so bad but it just it wasn't there
I didn't I didn't know what it was I
understand I'm Muslim about this I'm
gonna sit oh well that's that's your
religion that's a whole different God
and that doesn't make any sense and I'm
a Christian and I kept with my
Christianity until one day I kind of
clicked in my head and I'm like wait a
minute this is answering questions that
I've had all along let me figure out
what this is what were some of these
questions that you had one time what is
the Holy Spirit I can't explain it to me
whenever I went to church I would always
see people jump in screaming and say oh
this is the whole experience is how we
worship and praise God but I never felt
inclined to jump in screen and fall out
over the place when I went to church
that says it that's wrong for anybody
else but for me I never felt that no it
is a Holy Spirit how do you know that
it's not some other type of spirit
causing you to to jump in act this way
those are some of the questions that I
had yeah that's a good point and that's
one of the things beautiful things about
Islam that it calls you to think you
know it's not just about emotions and
being full of some kind of spirit and
you actually an academic I mean you're
someone who's pursuing a degree an MBA I
mean here's somebody who was using your
intellect your mind what God gave you
and your common sense and did you find
did you did you find that Islam was
connecting with what was in your innate
nature and with your intellect with me
when I saw that it was so simple it was
so direct you just connected creating in
that city
whooping hollering you don't have to
make your prayer better than the next
person spread because we're shown how we
should pray and Timmy just felt more
authentic like God I feel that God just
he shows us how to worship Him you don't
have to wanna bear you don't have to try
to figure out if my prayer was better
than the next guys for anything like
that the first time that I actually went
to a match kids I was so nervous I'm
like okay what's gonna happen in here I
don't know these people
I don't know where I'm going some
sisters grab me they said come we'll
show you how to print seven a lot of
crazy so we'll show you and when I put
my head on the ground I said wow this is
amazing I didn't know what I was feeling
but it just felt so amazing and as I
started being a Khurrana just about even
more amazing like there's an ayah in the
Quran in surah al oh if I can read it
okay absolutely yes okay um one
translation says do you see that if your
streams work so you come try then who
can supply me with clear flowing water
and I said Wow absolutely blew my mind
that and all the other think that read
and learns about the answered a lot of
the questions that I had Christianity it
just didn't my mind was amazing that's
interesting you said there's there's no
hoop and holler hey it's pretty
straightforward worship the crater not
the creation and then you put your head
on the ground I mean you didn't do
anything different than what Jesus did I
mean it's quoted in the in the Gospel of
Matthew that he went a little further
meaning referring to Jesus and he fell
on his face and he prayed to God that's
the god you're praying to so you do you
find more and more I'm sorry go ahead
it feels so authentic it's just
I can't describe it and I just I think I
like they were saying that he got any
two disappeared even when I had learned
about Islam before it still didn't
connect with me and I was still closing
it off like oh this is not for me this
is straining just a different guy and so
a lot of kind of opened my heart up to
it and then I just saw how beautiful
Islam really is do you find like most
people do who come I mean I've
interviewed many scholars of the Bible
of Christianity who the more they they
learned about Islam the more they saw
that this was the authentic original
message of all the messengers that
submission is surrendered to the creator
worshiping him doing his will on earth
as it is in heaven the same as you see
in the Lord's Prayer just worshiping God
no middleman nobody in the middle
between you and God no Saints no idols
nothing pure monotheism and then all the
other rituals that they grew up knowing
about but not knowing how to implement
but you see are you starting to see for
instance somebody now would look at you
and and you see Jesus's mother Mary you
cannot tell the color of her hair
because she's wearing what you're
wearing
so another tradition right there I mean
are you seeing this the more and more
you study Islam every day listen to your
actions when I'm at work I listen to
other teachers at work and at life
actually is starting to make more spin
then and if I may mention one of my
friends asked me if you become a Muslim
will you think eseni the hardest thing
for you and actually for her covering my
hair it's going to be by far the hardest
thing for me and there were a lot of
things to go along with that I'm not
going to get into we have only the time
but once I I converted it took me a week
before I started coming my hair the
months I covered my hair I felt amazing
I felt beautiful
I felt respectable
I didn't have to worry about is my hair
looking perfect today or is this person
going to like my hair is this acceptable
and it's just it's amazing all around
you just you find out more about
yourself in in about life as you go
through Islam more and more every day
we're gonna go take a break we want to
know about your parents reaction
I mean being from a really staunch
Christian background we have a lot more
to talk about with Bianca here in a Deen
show don't go anywhere
the question is about where the Muslims
are not good citizens the Constitution
defines what a good citizen is and the
preamble it says we the people of the
United States and I will form a more
perfect union establish justice insure
domestic tranquility to be Muslim I can
say that is a good Muslim and most
Muslims can say that Muslims in to
embrace that most Muslims are good
Americans back here with Bianca on the D
show so Bianca you made this very
important decision now before there is a
lot of misinformation out there and you
had mentioned that you had at one point
like most people thought that Islam was
of the devil yes and tell us about this
well Christian year I'm gonna say year
but I was taught that anything that's
not Christianity is of the devil as the
devil trying to distract you and things
that you don't need to get into things
that you don't need to worry about and I
think the media played a pretty big part
in what I thought about Islam and I'm
sure other people have seen things that
can seem a little scary a little
confusing in the media
so again just being taught to stay away
from those types of things and and I
thought it was up the devil with there
wasn't Christianity how did your mother
now is it your mother or also your
father who's a minister in the church
just your mother how did she respond
when how did you tell her give up paint
us a picture how did you did you just
come up to her and say
I've accepted as how did you break her
break into this conversation well I
didn't talk about converted because
first I was nervous and then I felt like
okay I just wasn't ready to have that
conversation with my room because I knew
where it could possibly go without being
necessary after three weeks I have
cranked it a lot of keys give me a
strength in the courage to just tell her
because I only have to keep her name I
walk up the house I won't have to worry
about wrapping my hair in the car we be
able to eat myself so I just went to her
and I said um do you remember when I
told you that I didn't fully believe in
Christianity or I didn't think it was
the correct way she said yes and I said
well I'm not a Christian and her mouth
kind of jobs a little bit and she's like
what do you mean so what are you and
that's that I'm a Muslim and she just
stared at me and I could tell but she
wasn't ready to talk so I left her alone
and a few hours later she came to me and
asked me so what confid you can make
that decision and i told her what it was
and she wasn't angry with me she said
you know I'm not gonna put you out
you're wrong we can make that decision
I'm very disappointed and I do not agree
but you're enough to make your own
decision there's a a really unique and
amazing story about a really just and
fair Christian King that the problem
Hamid peace be upon him when the Muslims
were being persecuted he sent them to
Abyssinia and there was this King there
who he said go and be with him to escape
persecution and he's a fair and just
ruler so at that time the pagan came
from Mecca they try to bring the Muslims
back and there was a court at that time
so I the Christian king joshey he got to
here he wanted to hear what because
again there was as negative propaganda
against the Muslims so he said let me
hear what you guys are about this
message so they recited some Quran they
explained Islam and he said these two
are from the same beams of light and he
accepted them in their Kingdom
he was just in fear later the more he
learned about Islam he saw that this was
the exact same message that Jesus
brought that submission is cemented to
the crater not to Crais he accepted
Islam
so I'm sure many people when they start
to really see the similarities and they
see that this is like you have seen the
original message of Jesus because
obviously many Christians also they
don't agree with this Trinity Father Son
Holy Ghost but when you tell them only
God just one God that's easy a child can
understand this absolutely I think that
for some Christians it's really hard to
accept that the Bible in the Quran have
by a common source because it's that
little thing the Jesus being God's Son
element that makes it completely
different and even had a Christian come
up to me when I was walking and
straitens it said you're gonna go to
hell and I said why is that he says
because you don't believe Jesus as the
Son about it and I said well show me
where Jesus stood that he was the son of
God and he couldn't show me and he just
kept going on and on about you just have
to have faith and you know the things
that a lot of your other and nobody can
show you this truth yet people want to
hold so tightly to this belief in it
after a while it doesn't make sense
yeah that's powerful when you ask people
I mean sincerely look if if I'm gonna go
to hell based on what you're saying
provide the evidence where did this
Jesus who we love and revere is one of
the mightiest messengers of God just
like Abraham Moses and all the other
messengers who brought the same message
of Islam submission to the Creator not
the creation where did he ever call
people to worship himself as a God or
literal son of God or that he came to
die for the sins of the world it's it's
nowhere you havn't big us statements
that you can interpret that way but
clear unambiguous it's not there now how
about many people they end up getting
the tears from Islam because of all the
negative hype propaganda against Islam
did this affect you and many people they
end up realizing if they investigate
Islam that Islam is the truth but
they're not courageous enough because
what is my what are my parents going to
say what is my community you're going to
say so they cover it up and they walk
away you didn't do that but did you have
that trepidation in your heart now
and I had to pray a lot to ask I lost
her give me strength because again it
took me a week before I even cover my
hair after I converted and I was nervous
I came with my job because when I came
to my job I was a Christian and I didn't
cover my hair I didn't dress a certain
way and now I'm coming in in the middle
of the week and I'm covering my hair and
buddy's like what were you having a bad
hair day
whoa I thought you just like the spell
and I have to explain to the dominie
Muslim in I think that maybe the media
it didn't play a part at first before I
even knew anything about Islam but once
I started learning about it it's like
you can't deny it you just can't you sit
and read Quran if you pray even before
you meet a parodic you just pray you
cannot deny it at all it's just so
amazing the main thing that we've seen
is is and the most important thing
obviously just connecting that heart
back to its maker all of the injunctions
that come now are just for our own
benefit all many people don't realize
that that everything that the crater
told us to do it's good for us and the
things he told us to stay away from its
harmful there's great wisdom behind it
so Islam is not just a bunch of do's and
don'ts but the main thing is connecting
to God alone dialing up to the crater
alone worshipping Him alone and then you
get to know your maker and then you just
want to please him you want to do what
he wants to do and then you get double
benefit because now you get the benefit
from all the good that he's told us to
do and this is so amazing
we're gonna take an outbreak and ask you
some more questions when we come back
how's that sound we'll be right back
with more with this one of the story
here on the D show don't go anywhere
Salaam says love all mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show so tell us now you
meet a Muslim and he starts to or the
person starts to tell you a little bit
about Islam and what else what else was
it did you watch somebody did you what
did you how did you find out about the
Deen show
show me a certain section for Islam and
just to gain more knowledge about it and
I came across a game show on YouTube I
just couldn't stop watching the episode
so it was interesting like from the
guests that you had on to the topics
that was just amazing and I kept
watching it and I gained so much
knowledge it was actually one of the
factors that helped aid me in my
decision to convert to Islam and lucky
that I did meet a Muslim and he started
teaching me about Islam and this is when
I was little Christian but not really
and he asked me okay with your Christian
that explain to me the Trinity and I did
and I thought I did a good job and he
said now think about what you just said
does that make any sense at all and I
said um actually no it doesn't make any
sense oh and he's like okay just do this
read the Quran learn about my religion
if my religion is better than yours
learn more and then become Muslim okay
and I'll learn more about it and their
answer have you made that proposition to
your mother to pick up the Quran and
just read it for yourself for herself
for people in general anybody that's
that's out there would you you strongly
recommend this in the first place but I
would definitely recommend that she beat
or anybody else treated just for
themselves and and just learn there's
there's a lot of different reasons you
can learn about it you can listen to
different apps you posted different
teachers listen to the Deen show and you
learn so much you'll learn so much tell
us Bianca you know that in the
university in this day and age you know
people are just going away from religion
what advice I mean from from your
experiences you you're going towards the
natural way you know the way that
because we know that the the same way
that the body needs nourishment food and
water the soul the soul needs that
nourishment it needs to be connected
with its maker and the side effect to it
not is depression
drug abuse and and all the other
pitfalls that people fall into and you
probably see this you see a lot of
people on antidepressants suicide is on
the rise and these are those direct side
effects of not nourishing the soul but a
lot of times people don't even want to
have that conversation right and and at
certain age bracket people they think
we're going to live forever just party
and wait for the weekend how did you not
fall into that or get out of it if you
were or how did you not fall into it
stay in it and get to where you are now
to even be thinking about more of
something noble like this station in
Baltimore I live in a big city and it is
everywhere you have friends I have
family members who go to clubs and hang
out and drink it and they might not be
you know they might not drink a lot but
even a little bit and you can see the
effects of it and I think that it's just
easy not to be religious or not to study
or have faith and it's it's fun for some
people always fun so a lot of sponges
that go dancing and drinking and hang
with your friends and not worry about oh
I need pray or I need to read the Word
of God or even to think about godless
easy how to do it for some people it is
fun so it does happen but like you said
we do need spiritual food and once you
start submitting to the creator you'll
find that you have joy and peace and
fulfillment even more and more and more
the more that you get into it and it
will help you to turn away from these
things yeah definitely Islam has the
solution for all of these social ills
and it's sad to see and we definitely
Islam if you look at is L AM Islam says
love all mankind and that's why we're
sharing because we truly want the best
for all of mankind and we truly believe
that because this is from the Creator
that it resonates with what's innate in
all of us and anybody who gives Islam a
fair shot looks at it sincerely won't
reject it as you didn't when it was
brought to you you were sincere true
seeker and here we are today on the Deen
show sharing your story
absolutely and I do think that Islam
deserves a fair shot from everybody
Christian Jew atheist and I was actually
was in to elect a straight the other day
and it was interesting that the teacher
said that dua is in prayer supplication
dua is proof that God exists for the
eighth year so for people who are short
goddesses and that's because if anything
happens see if she can history situation
to where you're deeply afraid or you
thought you're gonna die anybody help me
and that's for anybody and that's proof
that God is this and the Quran is so
much different from the Bible in in the
way it's laid out in the way that a lot
of speaks to you directly in not just
thinking so amazing that God and all of
his glory sent us down the Quran and
said let me explain anything to you let
me tell you how I need you I'm excited I
leave the earth and all these things
like he doesn't have to do that at all
and it's so amazing for us not hot
Saudia and not to pay attention to war
week yes this amazing point many people
now they don't know that Jesus he called
on the crater by the word Aloha because
he did speak English he spoke Aramaic
which is a sister language to Arabic and
you are just following that same
tradition now for the skeptics out there
they think okay she's been brainwashed
ko Hurst somehow and now she's going to
end up joining some fanatical group
terrorism associated with Islam you know
now she's subjugated what do you have to
say to him for yourself you know I think
sitting here talking all day about my
own experience and people have talked to
me about their own experience back when
I was a Christian and I didn't want to
hear it I said oh whatever that's you
that's your religion it's not for me you
guys are weird
but I encourage people to find out for
themselves read ask people ask Muslims
ask them about their personal story that
personal
struggles in personal situations then
you'll find out prey that's the first
thing you savage prayers just put your
neck to the ground and like people
always say like you say cuz I was to
create a dodgy you don't have to do a
name you don't have to say God or Yahweh
or wherever you call upon just the
Creator guide me and that's all you has
to do and I actually wanted to show you
this book that I found in the library do
you see it yes
Inuk Space Ghost mhm yes the natural
history far yes he said the NHIN is my
smokeless fire there standing in a
position where they can see us but we
can't see them I just find it
interesting that people who take all
this time to search for stuff that Allah
already laid out first in the Quran so I
just really encourage people to read for
themselves and find out it now yeah
instead of doing something like this
going all the way around the corner to
scratch your head or going around the
world to find it it's it's they're asked
like you said really basic ask the
crater alone to guide you that's the
first play place to start really simple
beautiful thank you so much for being
with us here on the Deen show may God
Almighty the creator continue to bless
you and to strengthen you and grant you
Jenna paradise thank you so much thank
you and that was Bianca here on the D
show with a fabulous story and so many
people are being just robbed and
neglected from hearing about the truth
but you got to tune in today and you got
to hear this wonderful story so she went
from being an a really staunch Baptist
household Christian household to now
being Muslim and then when we say Muslim
remember it's very important these key
points that Jesus was a Muslim because a
Muslim is one who surrenders and submits
to the crater alone worshiping God
Almighty the same God that Jesus worship
abc123 really straight forward because
Jesus really he was not a Christian nor
was Abraham or Moses they were all ones
who submitted themselves to God alone
to the Creator they worshiped the
Creator not the creation I'm talking
very slow and explaining because it's
very simple
easy to understand and you will find
this message over and over in the Bible
here o Israel the Lord thy God is one
now three and one Jesus when he was
approached and he said o good master
what good thing can I do them I may have
eternal life
he said why are you calling me good
there's only one good and that's God
that's the Creator and if you want to
enter into eternal life meaning paradise
keep the commandments and this is what
Muslims are doing and one of those
Commandments you saw but the main thing
is before we get into the do's and
don'ts which I had mentioned these are
things that the Creator prescribed
because they're good for us laws are
there in the society protect society and
that's why God Almighty he had revealed
certain commandment Commandments to
protect us and to benefit us things that
can benefit us he told us to do and
there's great wisdom and the things that
the Creator has prescribed for us and
one of those things that have been
prescribed is the the modest dress and
you'll see this over and over mention
also in the Bible what we have left
there of truth in it you'll see the call
to do what Bianca is doing worshiping
the crater and not the creation and
nowhere did Jesus ever say to worship
himself like she was asking know where
there's ambiguous statements but clear
unequivocal no but you see the pyramid
message of monotheism that Jesus called
- and then you see where for instance
Jesus's mother Mary what did she do she
wore hijab did Jesus before he was born
that Jesus's mother worshiped him who
was not even brought into this world yet
and then when he was a little baby was
she worshiping him as a guy no she was
worshiping the same God that our sister
now is worshiping Allah Allah hah and
Aramaic the sister language - Arabic now
I'm going on and because I want people
to see the commonalities and to see the
authentic the pure message that Muslims
are upon and you'll see in 1 Corinthians
you'll see that it says that a woman who
prays prophesizes
without her head covered she might as
well shave her head off she dishonours
her head it's in the Bible it's there so
bits and pieces of it are there but has
been altered has been changed and you
will get the that's why the crater sent
the Quran tamper free tamper proof and
it is the verbatim Word of God and the
final messenger probe Muhammad peace be
upon him and most people who are sincere
Troup seekers are seeing this the
message is resonating because it's
straightforward it's simple it's based
on logical proofs and evidences and you
can go ahead and learn more call us